en somme on
or nous n'avions pas la production des
précédents
trop génial et une pareille comme ça a
donné cette année on espère rapidement
et efficacement
donc tu me parlais pas sonné pour moi
pour commander matinée
[Musique]
ceux qui se souviennent de moi sur 110m
démocratie
cette situation que vous voyez en jeu
en pleine mutation j'étais formation une
action déjà jamais imposé sans ederson
s'est passé autrement
jours à lui pour les animaux a un ça va
pourquoi nous les a vus nous parlons
raison nous allons débattre
ou est-ce que de pérenniser l'événement
et j'en passe
je pensais que c'était pas
à côté de moi c'est parce que je ne sais
jamais munitions et d'un système de
radar ces questions
comme la nature ces civils des choses
dont je suis devenu agent à présent et
j'ai un fils qui
était temps que mieux sinon sinon
vivement
je sais par où commencer par me noirot
êtes juste une coïncidence mais montre
la réalité
et je vois c'est
que nous en sommes alors entrés samedi à
comines
une amie parce qu'ils travaillent
système
et
monfils et simon deux écoles
d'enseignement
il a raison qu'est ce que ça fait ça
fait mieux dans le même toit en face les
générations dont oublier ses généreux
opportunité à chaque fois finalistes de
se racheter et puis il dit sarah dennis
hopper
tabac ça c'était après avoir travaillé
pour l'alcool oui c'est des trucs un peu
dangereux c'est pas c'est pas très sexy
a raconté un enfant
du coup les conversations tournent
autour de ce que je fais est bon c'est
je concède volontiers qu'il est un peu
difficile pour un parent d'explication
fils que voilà je vend un produit
dangereux et puis je pensais aux gens de
bas touché à ce produit y compris
lui-même
c'est un paradoxe je le conçois c'est la
vie mais le déclic viendra quand sa
maman pour des raisons non souviennent
plus n'est pas disponible et puis je
dois je vais le papa maman donc il
arrive ce moment là où il ya la réunion
des parents d'élèves qui a organisé et
puis moi je dois me présenter là parce
que c'est sa maman qui fait d'habitude
ces choses et puis vint ce mouvement
l'enseignant demande à chacun à tous les
enfants de se présenter et d'y tuer tel
est ton papa c qui dans la salle ainsi
de suite donc quand son tour arrive à et
se présenta il présenta son papa et puis
curieusement l'enseignant de mona que
fait-on pas par
le gr il se retourne chez moi le regard
que le gène avec comme un petit appel au
secours vous imaginez bien mon embarras
que j'ai essayé de masquer mais bon j'ai
essayé en adulte voilà de trouver
quelques mots aux débats
je vendais des produits dangereux aulas
pour la santé
[Musique]
j'avoue que c'était pas c'était pas une
chose facile à faire mais bon on va
pouvoir se mouiller on doit pouvoir
manger mais cependant
ce jour là je ne l'oublierai jamais
parce que c'est le jour où j'ai eu le
déclic dans ma vie c'est le jour où je
me suis dit écoute il faut que tu vois
là on essaye de chercher de quoi nourrir
la famille on essaye chercher de quoi
payer les factures donner un peu au
village aux grands parents qui sont
restés là bas
mais on peut le faire dans un domaine
qui n'est pas aussi controversé que ce
que tu as fait jusque là c'est le jour
où je me suis dit il faut que je change
il faut que je change d'habitude il faut
que je change d'attitude il faut que je
change de fréquentation il faut que je
change de vie
contre nature c'est faire les choses les
mauvaises et les bonnes la nature ans
issus arranger les choses et puis
quelques mois et mais au fait
l'opportunité de rejoindre la société
que je dirige aujourd'hui est que bon je
vais passer par le forum pour présenter
la société dont du coup depuis lors je
suis dans le domaine des énergies
renouvelables et je vous assure quand
j'arrive à la maison je m'arrache le
torse bombé
voilà je suis fier aujourd'hui d'être
deux ans ce panel d'être devant vous de
vous parler de réchauffement climatique
mais surtout de comment
moi et mes équipes
utilisons le sonné comme un acteur dans
la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique
cela peut paraître paradoxal n'est ce
pas nadine au soleil on a vu des
présentations ondine au soleil c'est ça
qui crée le réchauffement climatique gaz
à effet de serre et tout ce que les
spécialistes durant je suis pas un
spécialiste du domaine quand vous avez
vu juste spécialiste plutôt dans
l'ingénierie informatique
non le soleil malgré le fait qu'il soit
comme dans le commun dans notre vision
commune la scène grosse houle au dessus
de nos têtes qui contribuent à
réchauffer la planète qui contribue à
nous faire pour senti mal et continuer à
nous empêcher de nous voir comme on veut
le développement technologique a fait en
sorte qu'il est possible d'utiliser le
soleil pour lui retourner c'est qu'il
nous faire c'est-à-dire l'utilisent pour
combattre contre le réchauffement
climatique et créaient comment est-ce
que ça se passe pour ceux qui ne sont
pas experts dans le domaine je vais
essayer d'expliquer ça de façon très
saine
nous avons des panneaux que nous
appellons couramment panneaux solaires
qui s'élève à capter la lumière du
soleil et puis celle lumière est
transformé et stockée dans des batteries
qui sont fabriqués et adapté à un usage
et c'est donc comme ça une énergie qu'on
appelle énergie zéro émission dans le
jargon c'est pas dit une énergie propre
énergie qu'on pourra réutiliser après
pour l'électrification une énergie qui
contribue à lutter de façon
significative contre ce réchauffement
climatique c'est une bonne nouvelle
n'est ce pas après cela nous utilisons
cette énergie pour éclairer nos
populations dans les zones rurales
laissées par les facilités qu'on a ici
dans ce très belle salle avec beaucoup
de lui on n'y arrive pas encore on va
peut-être y arriver un jour mais pour le
moment le fait de pouvoir apporter cette
lumière aux populations dans la nuit ça
apporte de la valeur significative à la
vie en nous voyant une image ces petits
garçons qui sont tous souriants le fait
de tenir comme ça cet outil qui leur
permet dans la soirée de réviser leurs
leçons ça veut dire que nous apportons
l'éducation aux enfants le fait comme ça
de paix m grâce à nos solutions parce
qu'aussi nos solutions fournissent des
téléviseurs permettent comme ça aux
populations de pouvoir s'informer sur
tout ce qui se passe autour de nous tout
ce qui se passe autour du globe ça veut
dire que nous apportons les informations
nous apportons le monde nous apportons
la vie mais au-delà de cela nos
solutions
électriques basée sous le soleil
permettent aujourd'hui d'avoir ce que
nous appelons des pompes solaires qui
facilite l'irrigation le maraîchage et
permet ainsi aux agriculteurs de
cultiver pendant les 12 mois d'une année
donc ils sont sortis de ce cycle là où
il ya la saison de plus et ancien
châssis de suite il peut faire le
maraîchage ils peuvent cultiver pendant
toute l'année je sais pas pour ceux
parmi vous qui ont fait le tour du pays
il y à des régions dans ce pays où on
passe 3 mois à 6 ans ne rien faire à se
ronger l'os parce qu'on n'a pas de
revenus parce qu'il n'y a pas de quoi
cultiver donc ces solutions aujourd'hui
permettent de générer des revenus
permettent et générer des richesses et
cela c'est grâce au soleil
parlant de richesse en effet l'argent
c'est le nerf de la guerre comme on dit
voilà donc aujourd'hui je sais pas pour
ceux parmi vous qui sont familiers de
ces sujets là une connexion électrique
standard ce qu'on appelle dans le
domaine de jargon le guide a dit
posséder une connexion électrique ça
coûte extrêmement cher
et ça c'est dans tous les pays du monde
les occidentaux ils ont les moyens ils
peuvent se permettre de financer cela
mais chez nous on a fait qu'on ne peut
pas se permettre ce luxe là
donc si on évalue le coût par exemple
chinois en afrique de l'ouest en moyenne
c'est au delà d'une centaine de milliers
de francs cfa 100 mille francs cfa
je sais pas si vous savez ce que ça
représente pour des populations
vulnérables dans les régions du pays
cent mille francs cfa
c'est l'équivalent parfois du budget
annuel d'une famille
un adage dit ventre affamé n'a point
d'oreille et bien je vais un peu aller
dans le même sens et moi je dirais
ventre affamé n'a pas besoin
d'électricité
alors c'est l'hypnose d'être facile
comme on est là dans ce luxueux palace
à parler de réchauffement climatique
assis au t2 l'eau minérale à boire des
boissons gazeuses
c'est bien beau tout ça est un parmi
nous qui ont cette possibilité et puis
nos dirigeants parfois d'aller dans les
grands forums internationaux des clans
colloque glasgow paris copenhague
60% top500 ainsi de suite
c'est bien beau aussi d'avoir nos
ingénieurs nos chercheurs qui vaut je
dis bien ceux d'ici et ceux d'ailleurs
qui vont pouvoir a peiné avec des
solutions tout aussi
intéressante et qui sont tagués de
climatique et autres
mais la réalité est que
toute conversation
toute idée toute solution que nous
voulons apporter au réchauffement
climatique doit se faire en impliquant
les populations parce que ce sont ces
populations qui à la fin de la journée
vont utiliser ces solutions et vont
permettre comme ça qu ensemble nous
luttons contre le réchauffement
climatique
mais comment est ce qu'on fait pour y
arriver nous par exemple on a développé
cette solution comme je disais des
panneaux solaires des solutions
énergétiques et autres nous nous
assurons au quotidien grâce à ses
solutions que nous développons et que
nous ajustons suivant le besoin des
populations à faire en sorte qu'il n'est
pas seulement la saucisse sa solution
d'énergie solaire mais qu'ils aient la
possibilité de monitorer de contrôler et
de surveiller leur consommation
nous faisons en sorte que parce que
cette solution coûte extrêmement cher
nous on est une société on a pu activer
le gros capitaux
et on donne ses solutions à ces
populations
un peu comme du crédit c'est à dire
elles n'ont pas à payer le gros montant
nous on aime on donne les solutions en
mode pay as you go comme on dit ça veut
dire vous avez besoin de l'énergie pour
100 francs eh bien vous utilisez votre
téléphone à mumbai monnaies ou ps
enfants et puis vous avez de la lumière
des connaissances france ont épuisé et
ben ça s'arrête donc ils ont la
possibilité comme ça de contrôler ce
qu'il consomme ils ont la possibilité
d'avoir de l'énergie à la hauteur de
leurs bourses parce que nous sommes
convaincus que cette lutte pour y
arriver il faut associer tout le monde
c'est en associant tout le monde que
nous le traitons comme ça des soldats
qui
rejoindront cette armée parce que plus
grand des 7 à mes plus grandes sont une
chance de gagner cette lutte de gagner
ce combat pour la planète
je vais vous donner un chiffre comme ça
ici au togo est ce que vous savez que
nous approchons les cent mille ménages
qui sont équipées de solutions solaires
si on fait la moyenne chez nous on a
fait quand on dit un ménage c'est en
moyenne cinq personnes dont ça veut dire
que nous avons cinq cent mille personnes
qui utilisent de l'énergie solaire ça
fait comme ça cinq cent mille
soldats que nous avons dans cette lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique et
nous pouvons en être très fier
[Applaudissements]
je vais réunir en faisant une flexion
personnel qui inspirait de
l'intervention d'al gore j'imagine que
vous connaissez tous al gore lors d'un
tel événement comme celui-ci c'était en
2016 à vancouver
l'ancien président américain l'ancien
vice-président américain désolé après il
a été candidat à l'élection et puis ça
n'a pas bien marché dont les manger
léger dégradé directement président dans
ma tête donc l'ancien vice-président
américain que nous connaissons tous être
un fervent supporter des causes
écologiques depuis plus d'une décennie
il était bien dans plusieurs aides ainsi
de suite il fait d'être les débats des
conférences et je pense que ça apporte
une certaine valeur ajoutée parce qu'il
utilise comme ça son réseau il avait
trois préoccupations
la première était celle de savoir
est ce que nous devons en tant qu'humain
ajuster nos mentalités dans cette lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique
la seconde était de savoir
quand est ce que nous allons faire ce
changement de mentalité
et la dernière était de savoir est ce
que nous sommes prêts a fait ce
changement de mentalité
car en effet c'est c'est bien beau de se
dit je veux changer
c'est bien beau de se dire je vais
changer at elle table pour ma des
objectifs 2030 2063 et autres c'est
parfois un peu comme ces objets pour ses
filles ce tour en début d'année le 31
décembre n'est assis à pour cette année
je vais devenir ceci je vais le dire
cela et puis il ya trois mois après on a
tout oublié
mais ça pourrait matic est très
importante parce que la question d'après
c est ce que nous sommes prêts quel est
le niveau de préparation que nous avons
tous en tant qu'être humain tout
effectuer ce changement de mentalité
pour que ce changement de mentalité il
soit effectif et surtout et je verse
cible
il conclura en dire en disant que balla
le changement de mentalité va se faire
parce qu'on n'aura pas le choix à un
moment au vu de l'évolution de la
construit matic ça deviendra une
question binaire
être ou ne pas être
pour ma part je pense que j'ai changé et
mon fils me pète être confirmée si vous
le rencontrez un jour pourquoi je pense
qu'on est pas obligé d'arriver à ces
extrêmes de questions mineures et autres
pour ma part je pense qu'en afrique il
est vraiment difficile voire impossible
d'être écolo par principe sadi du jard
s'est dit bon je vais aller au
supermarché voilà il ya bio ici qui
coûte plus cher que non bio mais
j'achète bio parce que par principe
price est déçus
parce qu'on a d'autres priorités on a
faim on veut manger
quand on veut se soigne et qu'on veut se
vêtit on va avoir un toit en vérité la
pluie le soleil on va pouvoir envoyer
nos enfants à l'école dans ces histoires
d'écolo de principe là ça marche pas ah
mais non les choses aux réalités locales
la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'il ya des
solutions qui existent
on a des ingénieurs très brillant qui
développe des choses il ya des solutions
qui sont adaptées au contexte africain
contexte rouler si on doit le ramener
ici
la solution énergétique solaire est une
solution viable qui a été démontrée et
qui fonctionne très bien
parce que nous avons le luxe en afrique
d'avoir le soleil un peu trop le soleil
même je dirais
donc est ce qu'on doit faire
moi je pense que on doit travailler tous
ensemble chacun autant qu'on ait à
rendre cette solution d'énergie solaire
accessible à tous comme le faisons
quand je pense que le combat pour le
réchauffement pour la planète où le
combat contre le réchauffement
climatique est un combat de tous
alors tous ensemble
mettons nous en ordre de bataille et
luttant contre le réchauffement
climatique de façon effective et
irréversible je vous remercie